it is upon us every Messiah every
religious ontology every manager of
every booth that this exhibit is
reflecting a distorted scintilla of the
spiritual reality of the transcendental
object at the end of time every one of
us is a particular eyes and distorted
image of this transcendental object into
which we are being dissolved into which
global culture is dissolved so
well so what so we can cut into this
cycle at any point we can become aware
of it we can become part of it we can
deny it there is no loss in the circuit
there is no blame becoming them what
psychedelic means is it means claiming
this dimension as your own you know
Plato said time is the moving image of
eternity that moving image of eternity
can be beheld in the silent darkness of
the mind on five grams suicide and if
you if you think the universe is by the
day if you think there are no more
frontiers to cross no more adventures to
be had I'm telling you you can turn your
living room into the bridge of
Magellan's on a long Saturday evening
with 5 grams of psilocybin and silent
darkness we are living in the most
empowering age in human history because
all of the energy of the ancestors not
only the human ancestors but our animal
our primate ancestors all that energy
pours entity is focused into this moment
we are the transition generation we have
one foot in matter and one foot in
hyperspace and we can redeem the trust
of thousands of years all of the horror
of history can be redeemed if we don't
drop them all everything wrong every
instance of racial sexual or minority
persecution can be redeemed if we give
the human adventure meaning and we give
of meaning by discovering the totality
within ourselves and then amplifying it
for each other and this dissolves
boundaries empowers the weak enlightens
the strong and brings hope to all and it
can only be done if we accept the gifts
which major has offered us thank you
very very much
the last thought I want to leave you
with which is a sort of a coincidence
cause eternal thought because it will
bum some and exalt others is the one
thing that I've learned from
psychedelics that seems secure over all
the decades and the you know embracing
one idea one ideology afternoon the one
thing that seems secure is a truth that
is hard to hear in the context of the
dominator culture with a obsession with
the material world and and that truth is
that nothing lasts nothing lasts you
know your enemies will fade your friends
will fade your fortune your poverty your
disappointments your dreams everything
is in the process of changing into
something else so your agony is about to
be as swage Don the other hand your
happiness is about to be destroyed so
the the obligation that comes out of
this realization is an obligation to the
immediate moment to this thing that I've
been calling the felt moment of
immediate experience it isn't who you
were or what you were or who you will be
or what you will be it's the felt moment
of immediate experience and this has
been robbed from us by media and by our
tendency to denigrate ourselves to see
the world in terms of the great ones not
here whoever they are
Aristotle Madonna Jesus whatever your
particular band is
the overcoming of neurosis of
unhappiness of toxic lifestyles is the
felt presence of immediate experience in
the body in the moment and you know
psychedelics sexuality gastronomy sport
dance these are the things which put you
in the felt presence of the moment and
that's really all you ever possess your
memories are eroding away the futures
you anticipate will mostly not come to
pass and the real richness is in the
moment and it's not necessarily some
kind of be here now feel-good thing
because it doesn't always feel good but
it always feels it is a domain of
feeling its primary language is not
primary in theology is not primary the
propagation of future and past vectors
is not primary what's primary is the
felt presence of experience and that is
the source of love and that is the
source of community
if so I'm if someone had never taken
psychedelics and had no interest in it
and had come here because they thought
this was the Trey Goering group I think
they would be truly alarmed and
disturbed by what they hear because we
appear to be mad people because we
appear to be fully engaged with an
unseen invisible world we're calling it
the cause of history the purpose for the
future and the basis for everything
going on between us but nobody said life
was simple because every single person
who does this is seeing things no human
eye has ever fallen upon and it is a
realm of ideas and we do each bring back
different souvenirs from that place we
are all equally qualified we don't know
who will spot the whale but everyone
should have their eye peeled because
that's what we're doing we're searching
for an encounter with Leviathan nature
is God that was the informing vision
moby dick and it's a good one to carry
as a metaphor into this into a
psychedelic experience there again was a
perfect example of the male ego unable
to release into the matrix of nature
until it literally dragged them into the
depths through the building of community
through the music and the dissolution of
boundaries through the use of these
psychedelics the Shaymin are showing how
you create an archaic style culture
after 5,000 years of human history
because we can't abandon technology we
have six billion people on this planet
but the shame and the rave culture are
showing us how we can take what was best
in the society of twenty five thousand
years ago and bring it into the center
of our lives and live it again and
create a community of caring intelligent
people who've got their heart connected
to their head and their heart connected
to their feet so that through dance
feeling philosophy sexuality art we
manifest the creativity that is going to
be necessary for us to save ourselves
this is the key you see if the expansion
of consciousness does not play a major
role in the human future what kind the
future is
going to be
in mind goals are very modest I'm very
pleased that it chose to confide so
concrete an idea in me but if it had
never chosen to do that I still would
die a happy man with the unspeakable
experiences of beauty that it has shared
with me because my psychedelic trips
these days are not about the time life
the time wave is pretty much a done a
done deal so I think it's like
everything else in life intent is
everything and impeccability means in
that domain do not seek to use do not
seek to use it's a religious mystery and
that doesn't mean it's an unsolved
problem it means a mystery and life is
only worth living as long as the
mysteries continue to inform transform
and inspire us and the last thing I want
to say and then I'll leave you is the
truth can take care of itself you don't
have to approach the truth with eyes
lowered and gaze averted on bended knee
that's how you approach [ __ ] but the
truth is so powerful that you can kick
the tires
over the engine check the odometer and
nobody is offended truth is real it can
stand the test and that's why you know I
went all over the world looking at
various spiritual traditions I don't
feel it splitting them down to say that
they were ineffective because they were
all great aspirations but the only real
open doorway that I ever found were the
planes this works you know in other
spiritual disciplines everybody wants to
go faster they want the Roshi to give
them further empowerment's they want
further information postures secret
teachings so forth and so on once you
reach the psychedelic experience the
accelerator is far less interesting than
the location of the brakes that's what
we're looking for we're not trying to
push we all know how to push this so
fast we can't stand it
we need a feeling of unity feeling is
primary
so it doesn't come out of intellectual
exort Asian it comes out of a personal
act of courage made by the individual an
act of courage which involves surrender
surrender is the opposite side of the
coin of ego the central issue of our
times is our inability to surrender to
what we know is right we have the
ability to feed the hungry we have the
ability to educate our children to clean
up our environment to eliminate sexism
to eliminate racism the question is can
we change our minds fast enough not can
we change our minds but can be changed
them fast enough
a return to archaism with the lessons
learned in history that's where we were
happy the fall was a fall into a veil of
Tears into a world of limitation and
pain and suffering and infectious
disease and so forth and so on
it's a prodigal journey into a lower
dimension that can now be ended by a
collective cultural decision to commit
to this taoist shamanistic feminized
cybernetic caring aware
present kind of being it's nothing more
than what each of us is in our very best
moments but we have to extend those very
best moments to fill whole lifetimes
that's interesting
the age thing that's great
oh man makini it must be approaching
2012 now